اقرئيس ديني برجوجينا رجل الاعمال الروسيه
المقرب من الرئيس اليوم
ومؤسس مجموعه فاجنر بانه تدخل في
الانتخابات الامريكيه وقال بريكوجين في
منشور على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لشركته
كونكورد لقد تدخلنا في الانتخابات
الامريكيه تدخلنا ومازلنا نتدخل وصنواصل
التدخل نعرف كيف نفعل هذا بطريقهنا الخاصه
وبحرص ودقه وثلاثه اضاف بريكوجين في
منشوره خلال عملياتنا المتناهيه الدقه
السنه ستصلوا الكليتين والكبد دفعه واحده
دون ان يوضح ما الذي اقصده في هذا التعليم
في المقابل قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
لاداره الرئيس لن تتسهل مع التدخل في
الانتخابات
عن مصدر ذلك تدخل وقالت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض
ان تصريحات جيني بريكوجين بشان التدخل في
الانتخابات الامريكيه غير جديده غير
مفاجئه وان كيانات مرتبطه
كانت وراء محاولات التدخل في الانتخابات
لا تاتي بجديد او مفاجاه من المعروف
والموفق جيدا ان الكائنات المرتبطه بكيني
بريكوجين ساعات للتاثير في الانتخابات في
جميع انحاء العالم بما في ذلك الولايات
المتحده وقد عملت الولايات المتحده على
سطح حمالات التاثير الخبيث لروسيا
ومكافحتها لذها فان بريكوجين فاعل سيء
معروف ومشمول بالعقبات في الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي